[Applause]
let's talk about the 80s bro i just want
to start off because i've been listening
to your project
and it is truly nostalgic
yes in every capacity yeah i saw you
riding around in the old school bends
yeah and the delorean delorean i got the
bands i got the uh
the royce the rolls royce 1984. what
year were you born in
i was born in uh i'm a 90s baby okay
yeah because i was born in 87 so i don't
even remember the 80s
yeah so what um why the 80s
um basically i
i'm in love i love movies
you know i love movies and i have my
favorite movies you know and
one thing that i found myself um
so so i stopped doing drugs for a while
okay and i'm proud of myself
i don't for a while does that mean
you're like doing them again now
no it means for a long time i haven't
done them
okay and congratulations thank you so
much and
i feel like i found
what i found my drug and
it was john hughes movies oh wow
pretty in pink yes yeah i think so
um just like those 80s movies like the
yeah breakfast the breakfast club was
fine yeah all the just
just like all those movies even home
alone you know like all those movies you
know
and um they make me feel
like when i was an immigrant in a
different country
because i'm not from america right so
when i was in a different country i
would watch the tv as a kid and be like
yeah i wish
i lived in a house i wish i had all
these
uh family members running around i wish
i had like a kitchen a refrigerator and
a microwave and
my own room and stuff like that and that
that was like my dream
to have that like that was always my
dream and
um i watch sorry about that i
watch and listen i watch and listen
um to 80s music
to feel like a kid
and uh that's my drug so i eat a lot of
food
i have a lot of random sex okay so
random sex
food and 80s movies with 80s music and
that's what
got me to 1984 and i did 1984
2015. i just never put it out so this is
a
five-year-old album and now uh
it's funny because the 80s have such a
like distinct
sound and i would almost argue that like
the popular consensus might be that 80s
music might
maybe it's aged worse than most other
decades of music
yeah wouldn't you say like i don't know
but but it's just
i think it's dope because obviously it
was a very um
brave and
you like like you did a whole album yeah
you know what i'm saying i'm 94. you
really committed bro
yeah i mean you know i 2020 is the new
1984.
and um i'm glad i put it out now